When a dead man rises.
How does he come to bear with his unnatural existence?
For every story deserves an ending, and without one what is there to treasure?
So he looks for purpose in his undeath, a notoriously difficult task.
But, even accursed undead want to believe they're special, it seems.
First he joins a legion, united in their resolve. A pack of wolves,
sworn to do battle with the dark where ever it arises. The same dark they say that is responsible for the curse of the undead.
Battling against horrors and monsters like heroes past.
Battling themselves, for that is where the true corruption lies.
Until one day the man turns coat and leaves, unable to bear the burden.
For even in undeath, Hawkwood feared his mortality.
He clutched a shield close to his chest, unlike his brothers and sisters. He fought with a blade designed to catch and deflect mortal strikes.
Hawkwood the craven; the crestfallen.
However, by nature of definition, it is the coward who is capable of the highest heroism.
For his obstacles, are the greatest of all.
"Are you the next Monarch? Or merely a pawn of fate?"
He believed that he could still be a hero. A champion to banish the dark with the light of the first flame.
Someone worthy of a throne, a place in this world that is engraved with his name.
Hawkwood, an undead worthy of fire.
But again, he failed. A nameless accursed that undead. Unfit even to be cinder, and so he becomes ash.
When a dead man rises he becomes his failure. Forced to know that his best was not nearly enough.
"Ah, another one, roused from the sleep of death."
"Well, you're not alone. We unkindlled are worthless."
"We can't even die right..."
"Gives me conniptions. And they'd have us seek the lords of cinder and return them to their molding Thrones?"
"But we are talking true legends, with the mettle to link the fire."
"We're not fit to lick their boots."
"Don't you think?"
Each of them a man who actually became a fire linking King.
"Not for virtue, but for might. Such as a lord, I suppose."
"But here I ask, do we have a sodding chance?"
How could ashen failures possibly hope to convince four Lords to listen to them?
Well, if the Lord's will not return to their thrones themselves.
Let them return as cinders.
"You offed the Lords of Cinder, the Undead Legion..."
"So that's how they're delivered to their thrones?"
"I pity the sorry Souls..."
""Is that really, Lordships last reward?"
It finally hit him, the absurdity of it all.
"The poor wretched souls. Be they Lord or legend the curse shows no mercy..."
"What a sham..."
And if Kings could not escape their fate? Well, then they were no lesser than he.
So what did he have to fear? Nothing.
"I'm a deserter, I know. But I've still plenty of fight in me!"
First, he followed the wolf. Then he was scarred by fire.
Finally, he finds the courage to pursue another calling. The calling of those who seek to exist outside of the cycle.
But to be alive, is to be vulnerable. And even the fiery gods, no exception to that rule.
No, the Apostles of the Dragon seek another plane of existence.
One which transcends life. And we, possess one of their relics.
"Oh, you've returned. I was hoping to see y'. That crestfallen arsehole, he handed me this."
"He's changed a great deal since he left this place."
"Graven of face, he asked me to give it y' "
It was a challenge. This time he fights for something else completely, without a shield to protect his own self.
"Ah, there you are..."
"Well, I've decided to stop running from my fate."
"Loathe me. All you like,"
"I shall take what makes you Dragon."
"This shall be no petty theft."
"As the true dragon I shall take what is rightfully mine."
"Ah, I should have know... Enough, you fool!"
"Oh, be as bloody mad as you like... Trapped within your wretched clast..."
"You are, a dragon."
"More dragon, than I."
"A deserter could hope for no better place to die..."
His name was Hawkwood, the last remaining warrior of the undead legion.
This video is sponsored by
Me if you enjoy my content, If this prepare to cry made you cry;
Then you can now support them. And, you get something comfy in return.
So just scroll down, and you'll see shirts and hoodies below the video.
You guys also know that I love working with artists, and this was a rare opportunity to work with a legendary one.
This is the hugely talented Cbot.
And this guy is a real Ariamis!
Just take a look at some of the art that he creates.
Our piece is this demonic version of my YouTube character.
He comes in 4 different colors.
And he stands, flame in hand; and it's got an eclipse in the background.
And he's surrounded by a field of familiar weaponry.
I think this part is really cool. See if you can put a name to all of the weapons here.
So, only really avid fans will realize that
this shirt is related to Dark Souls, and this shirt is related to my channel.
So, I think it's abstract and stylish enough for you to want to wear it in public.
And that's kind of the line I wanted to walk.
I've made sure that I sampled all of these products before hand. So I can vouch for their material quality.
I would just want to say, be aware if you choose a dark color for the background.
Because the weapons might not be completely visible, but light colors work really well.
As always, thank you for watching. I hope you enjoy the merch, and I'll see you next time.
And, there is something huge, just around the corner. So look forward to that.
Bye-bye.